the jurogan experience so
that's going to be this summer they
don't do it with crowds that's a good
question i don't know yet so
the japanese prime minister made an
announcement public statement saying hey
listen we're going to host the olympics
this summer no matter what
one of the interesting things about it
is although it's happening in 21 they're
still calling it tokyo 2020.
i think they were saving face for all
the marketing material that they already
made that cost them billions of dollars
right
zero to a one is that really worth five
billion dollars or whatever it is
interesting but it's going to be
interesting how they
figure it out because the olympic
village is like a town
there's 10 000 coaches and athletes from
every country
on the face of the planet all put into
a one mile radius on this olympic campus
and there's just so much interaction
engagement i'm talking the
the cafeteria at the olympic games is
five football fields long they've got a
mcdonald's
like a full-size mcdonald's in the
cafeteria
in the olympic village they've got foods
from all different parts of the country
you've got an italian station a japanese
station american station
you know and a pan-african station they
have
it's insane and you have literally
thousands of people swirling in at all
times it's 24 hours
at the moment bro like
for if you're coming from america you
can go down the street there's a
mcdonald's within
you know a mile of anybody while you're
here stateside but if you're coming from
one of these smaller countries are you
coming from guinea basal
or you're coming from i don't know qatar
like you're like damn
mcdonald's sounds pretty good i don't
get this at the crib let me go hey grab
me a little quick
couple mcchickens a couple double
cheeseburgers put them in the room
but you would think someone competing in
the olympics would want to fuel their
body with the best
possible food available some of them
know they can't win
you know like everyone going to the
olympics isn't expecting to win a medal
like
90 i say 90 large very large percentage
of the competitors at the olympic games
it's a long shot for them to get on the
podium they're going with the
expectation like hey listen
i'm representing my home country with
pride i
am going to a country that i've never
been before hopefully i can be on tv my
family will be watching me back home
the opening ceremonies is the best
experience for them because they get to
be
in a full packed arena around all the
athletes that they've seen on tv
but they know that realistically they're
not going to win so when that mcdonald's
is open 24 hours they're like let's go
bro we going here do they have to pay
for it
free oh that's everything's free that's
good so it's
it's uh it's an interesting perspective
being the olympic village it's
it's a cool spot it's got to be a wild
experience to be there it must feel so
real
it's it's wild so they're really strict
with the way
that they administer athletes and and
people to get in you have to have a
guest list if you want to bring anyone
in
they have to be approved seven days in
advance so let's say my wife i'm like
hey i want my wife to come into the
olympic village check out our living
space
check out the free mcdonald's then i
have to put her on the list seven days
in advance and it has to
be approved by the usopc and then also
you know the ioc wow and so it's it's a
it's a very
they're literally an athlete they're
like bro they're not playing dog i'm
telling you
i'm telling you joe like they get it
after and he's like
oh after he was done well that makes
sense well he's taking that out he's
taking that home with him he's put
he's putting that all in his suitcase
he's going to go start him
a little mcdonald's of his own when he
gets back to the crib but it's uh
so when you get in the village you have
to
it's almost like going through tsa at an
airport you got to show them your badge
they scan it you got to get all your
bags checked and make sure that you're
good to go you don't have any you know
thing lethal in your bags you get inside
and it's literally like an apartment
complex huge apartment complex
mcdonald's is the most popular
restaurant that's
crazy there listen and they're not
they're not
they're not getting salads and chicken
selects
no you know they're getting
cheeseburgers and mcchickens and
you're saying but i i listen hey
whatever you need to do to
be the fastest man in the world do your
thing well i guess also like when you're
done you probably just
want to treat yourself you're probably
needing very strict for a long period of
time
yeah crazy i that was my when i won the
gold in 2012 my first meal afterwards
was mcdonald's
very first good job good job i had
double cheeseburger
with a high sea orange to drink and a
large fry so crazy story i'll tell you
the story
so i win the olympic gold and right
after you win
they take you back to what they have
like a media house so it's got all of
the publications
from all over the world you've got ap
sports illustrated
nbc you know just pretty much everything
and so you go back and you just bounce
from room to room it's like okay we got
al michaels here we got bob costas here
we got you know joe rogan here and so
you go you show your medal you tell them
about your experience where you're from
who you are what you're gonna do with
all this money and fame that you've just
won and then so
as soon as you're ushered out of there
you competed at eight o'clock and you
don't get out of there to close to
midnight
so by the time it's midnight in london
really the only thing open
is mcdonald's right so i'm still in my
podium outfit like literally what i wore
on the podium i'm still
in it at midnight and so we go down to
like piccadilly
in in london and only things open is a
mcdonald's and so we went to like a club
for a little bit
one of my sponsors at the time had like
bottle service they wanted to celebrate
me so we leave there
we go to mcdonald's i get inside and
packed clubs just let out everyone's
like
hungry they're hungover they just got
done for the night full of drinking
they're all in line lines crazy i go
into the mcdonald's my damn i've been
this long day i wrestled all day long i
do not want to stand in line i just want
to see if i can
work my way to the front so i go and ask
the guy i'm like yo bro listen i just
wrestled all day
at the excel center i just won an
olympic gold like you think i can get in
front of you
and he's like you ain't winning what
stop and i'm like bro i'm like i won the
olympics he's like
no you didn't i had my medal in my
pocket
i have my gold medal in my pocket so i
pull my gold medal out and show this guy
he's like starts going nuts oh my god
this guy so he's yelling everyone he's
pushing people out of the way
in this mcdonald's he's like this guy
just won olympic gold medal let him to
the front of the line let him the funnel
and so he's pushing people out of the
way gets me
like literally escorts me to the front
of the line
to get me my quarter pounder and my
large fry
it was wow it was wild that's the
craziest cheeseburger fry story ever
cool it was it was dope it was awesome
that had to be very memorable it was fun
wow
that's fun winning the gold medal what i
mean
you i know you've won the world
championship what four times four worlds
won
olympics but how much difference nothing
like it
olympics are the best it's it's rare it
only happens every four years it's a
single day event so you have to be your
best on that single day you only get one
cycle to prepare for so we think of our
careers like cyclically
where like in a if you're an mma fighter
you're like okay i can get an
opportunity to fight for the belt
as long as i continue to compete at a
high level like keep my brand awareness
um at a at a good place but in wrestling
the pinnacle is the olympic game so no
matter how many world championships you
win you want that olympic gold
and the crazy thing is the worlds are
harder than the olympics so the olympics
are a little more condensed
in terms of the qualification process so
at worlds
it's much easier to qualify so you have
42 guys in your weight class or in your
bracket at worlds you only have 16
at the olympics so in the world
championships i won in 2015
i wrestled six matches the olympics i
won in 2012 i only had four matches
and so and it's it's it's a random draw
too so you could wrestle russia first
round
which would suck or you could wrestle
puerto rico
first round which would suck less
so it's a it's a really interesting
experience the way these brackets are
drawn
and i think that the olympic games has
become so special because of everything
surrounding it you get more money more
notoriety
uh more recognition moving forward like
winning the goal in 2012 catapulted me
to where i am right now like when i'm
recognized or announced at an event it's
always affiliated
with that olympic gold olympic gold
medalist jordan bros like they always
tell you whenever you step off the
podium you will forever
be an olympic gold medalist you can't
lose that you can lose your belt
right you can never lose your gold right
it always comes home with
me at the end of the day no matter what
i do moving forward so that's pretty
cool
that is an interesting perspective right
because if you're a fighter
you win the title and then you lose the
title in your next fight you're a former
world champion
but uh olympic gold medalist from 2012
is an
olympic gold medalist yeah so that's
it's dope yeah you made it through you
did it and that's it but then there's a
another guy who was four years later
yeah it's uh
it's interesting it's got to be a crazy
experience
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience